voilà nous allons être obligés de rendre
l'antenne pour suivre des 24 heures du
mince et d'un moment peut-être un peu
mal choisi mais qu'est ce que vous
voulez à vous le mans un set crucial de
roland garros interrompu en plein milieu
pour suivre un autre événement sportif
une frustration ultime que vivaient les
passionnés de tennis au début des années
70 rendez vous donc à 19h45 pour la fin
la suite et la fin de ce match ici
roland garros avoue le studio et oui ce
n'est pas sans un petit pincement au
coeur que de nous devons quitter roland
garros et je vous promets que vous
verrez les derniers échanges en différé
à cette époque où la france n'avait que
trois chaînes les matchs en direct de
roland garros n'occupait qu'une maigre
place à la télévision
pourtant le président de la fédération
française de tennis le savez la survie
du tournoi dépend des de sa présence
dans l'immédiat nous sommes sensibles au
fait que toute cette télévision en
direct doit être donnée au public
français
et combien en fait vous nous obliger à
nous battre pour garder ce tournoi car
elle est pas possible on n'a pas le
droit
quand vous faites des efforts que vous
faites pour envoyer dans les plus petits
villages des images de tennis va tout
faire pour garder ce tournoi anglais à
la fin des années 70 le tennis se
popularise le tournoi a diffusé à
l'époque sur tf1 occupe plus de place
dans le paysage télévisuel
selon nos estimations en neuf ans les
retransmissions passe de 45 à 140 9
heures en 1987
l'année suivante tf1 est privatisée et
cède les droits de diffusion à fr3 et
antennes des je crois que nous avons
bien travaillé avec un fer 3 cette année
et nous avons déjà pris des dispositions
pour travailler encore plus l'année
prochaine
alors pour montrer davantage de matches
deux chaînes pour montrer davantage de
matches une aubaine pour les
organisateurs de l'événement en 1988 290
heures de matches sont diffusés presque
deux fois plus que l'année précédente
après une dégringolade dans les années
90 le nombre d'or de retransmission
repart à la hausse en 2002 année où
eurosport a qu'à une partie des droits
[ __ ] et en 2005 avec la création de france
4 l'année dernière 250 8 heures de match
était diffusé
et depuis 2006 roland garros sans vite
aussi sur les mobiles
les fans peuvent passer d'un match à
l'autre en un clic ce service de gael
monfils était jusqu'à présent disponible
sur votre téléviseur il est dorénavant
sur votre portable
cinq cours au choix et en direct mais
aussi des petits programmes fabriqués
par des journalistes spécialement dédié
aux téléphones mobiles
aujourd'hui les applications mobiles
pour suivre le tournoi se sont
multipliés en 40 ans roland garros s'est
définitivement imposé comme événement
télévisuel incontournable
[Musique]